all right youtube last time we spoke you
said you were setting up a watch party
to watch the premiere episode
did you continue to watch the season
ah no
we saw i stopped after like episode
three
yeah i stopped watching
but we did watch our wedding we watched
our wedding when in the episode the
school sometimes my friends even be like
oh man we show you what how like
i'm like i don't even know what you guys
are talking about from what you did
watch this season was there anything you
learned about yourself or something that
you feel like you'll do differently
i might regret it i mean after watching
it i would never be
that mean to you
like it's so funny because like i
adore kobe like he is
100 to love my life and like i
when he got here and like this obviously
wasn't like on camera but like when he
got here like i made him breakfast in
bed every day for like three months and
like i packed his lunches when he goes
to work you know like i'm just like i'm
just so in love with him more and more
like each day
so watching it i was like oh my gosh
like the part where you told me to like
shut the [ __ ] up i don't even need your
help
your ring's so rude
i'm being rude
can you just shut the [ __ ] up
so i'm like absolutely like you should
have said that a minute ago like you
should have like
so definitely like somebody was like
there are so many ways you should have
used that show with kobe
oh no
it's funny because like a lot of like
when people
comment on me i'm just like no i agree
with you like i i shouldn't have done
that you know i shouldn't have said that
like i shouldn't have done that so
um yeah just looking back
i mean
i can say that there is no perfect
relationship you know it's all about
learning each other building a future
happy home that you guys want and
when i first got here i know i myself i
wasn't perfect
and
but i'm happy where we are right now
because you know we're looking at the
bigger picture here having a beautiful
home with the kids that's what matters
yeah well what's your response kobe to
those who might feel as if emily doesn't
deserve you i mean they're not in my
position to tell me who deserves me or
not who i deserve
so this is between us to work on that so
i
i mean
talk is cheap everybody can say whatever
they feel based on what they were
watching but we are
involving this together so do you think
i deserve it of course i mean
she's my wife
oh i'm so cute
well you have a beautiful baby girl now
scarlett
who is coving
she's adorable
how have you been being parents of two
now how what is that dynamic done for
your relationship
um well it is so much fun like
uh we love our kids but i think it even
brought us closer together because he
missed so much when cobin was born and
like he missed 17 months so like to see
him and like be in the delivery room
with him and like holding her for the
first time and like really experiencing
like having a baby baby
um it definitely brought us closer
so and he he wasn't working at the time
so like it was really nice he would like
take cobin and like i could nap with her
or like breast feed her and like copen
and then would be like at the park you
know so i did get like one-on-one time
with um where he got one-on-one time
with coping because like he obviously
had
a new baby sister and like right before
she was born he got like kicked out of
our bed he got in his a bedtime routine
he got potty trained and then like a
month later he had a baby sister so it
was a lot for him
to um take on but he is absolutely
obsessed with her he uh adores her yeah
so it's really fun to watch them
like bond together yeah and you feel
like kobe your bond you and koben's bond
has strengthened because for a while you
know he was still getting used yeah um i
can say that when i first go yeah i
wasn't working and it was a good thing
because
i used that period that moment in my
life because i was working a good bonus
yeah i was working so i would just leave
i was taking cobin to work with me and
then
yeah for nanny and so then um when he
got here like he just took over the
whole like all day for like eight to ten
hours a day and they
really connected it's so cute and now he
goes to work and i'll be like daddy's on
his way home and he like i have to tell
him like right when kobe tells me he's
coming home or else he won't stop asking
me he's like where's my dad where's my
dad yeah
that's so cute and you're a girl dad now
you know girl dad that's the thing
yeah oh she's wrapped around his finger
for sure yeah
all right emily well let's talk about
your dad let's get into the hard-hitting
question
yeah okay yeah
what's your response to viewers who feel
as if you take advantage of your dad's
kindness
um well no you only see one side of our
life um i definitely
my dad is a saint he literally would do
anything for any of there's five of us
for any of his children i don't think i
take advantage of his kindness you know
he just he's very open arms about it and
like even now he's like move out when
you're ready because we've been looking
for houses but
the market is terrible right now and
there's nothing we love and so
i don't know i feel like i just you know
i mean i'm a daddy's girl for sure
but
i don't think i take advantage of him
and i know it seems like that but i
really don't kobe takes care of the
animals i do the cooking and a lot of
the cleaning like you know we do
pull our weight around the house so it's
not like we just sit here and do nothing
and i worked it you know people love to
talk that i don't have a job i'm like
i've had a job since i was 14. like
you know whatever you said you watched
the episode your sister mentioned after
you told your parents you were pregnant
that you know you tend to
not really see the impact that you have
when you make your decisions i feel like
emily takes advantage of my parents and
everything they have here and she
doesn't really realize the full effect
of all of her actions sometimes what's
your response to that
well
when she said that i was like
no i can see how it looks that way
obviously we did get pregnant by
accident we really did use an app and
was it really by accident though guys
because
kobe wasn't using the method the you
know the method i pulled out when we
started and then you told me you have
this application on your phone
like i'm not ovulating right now you
can't me
so so what's that right
here's the thing is i was like okay so
we use con
now we are not having another baby
but he first got here it had been two
years and i was like wow i want to have
a lot of sex with you right and so i'm
like i downloaded this app you know and
we're both catholic i'm like we're gonna
do like the natural birth control like
parent planning and so i'm like i
downloaded this app and it was just like
this is when
you don't have to pull out and this is
when you do
and i am crying and believe that
i will be so scared i know and you know
what hey guys before we took that
pregnancy test like two weeks before i
actually took another one just to make
sure i wasn't pregnant and i was not so
i was like oh okay it's working like i'm
you know we're like working with my
object you know ovulation or whatever it
was it was really it was an
accident it really was because when we
did find out in the pharmacy it was like
oh
my gosh and like we want to move out
like i wanted to move out robin and i
back from got back from china i was like
okay i'm gonna move
you know out of my parents house um and
then i was pregnant so then they were
like well don't move like you can't move
out you know like just stay here with
the baby and then thank goodness i
didn't because then covet hit and so it
was like
i had my parents here and then kobe got
here and my dad was like well you can't
work so like you guys can stay here and
like i have savings but i didn't want to
blow my savings knowing that i was gonna
have another baby and i was gonna be on
maternity leave and then he couldn't
work so it just made sense to stay here
and like we do
pay my parents um
which
i mean we do pay them i'm not going to
say how much but
we do contribute you know so and like
kobe any projects my dad has kobe is
like more than hands-on and it's like
yes let's do it let's get it done so i'm
like why we live with you let's like
help fix up the house and let's you know
pull our way even more than we already
did because
we've had another kid teach us not to
but you know what it's not like our
other kid
made the bills go up okay she was
breastfed and if there was formula we
would have paid for it we paid for the
diapers we paid for everything okay it's
not like she was like
using
the electricity and like whatever so
it wasn't really that expensive to add
another kid
you know
i could see people in the comments now
like what yes it is expensive to have
another kid i know i have a fan question
april says quote you don't listen to
kobe's wishes on anything so why did you
listen to him about not using birth
control
april i do
do his wishes
um
i don't know because i okay i hadn't
been on birth control for years and kobe
was very much like do not take it so i
was like okay
i love you we're gonna use an app and
it'll be fine so yeah
but
i do listen to my husband and there's
proof right there that i do listen to
him
where he fell here scarlet babe
kobe do you still think that emily is a
little bossy and controlling uh that's
just who she is it's not
that's just what she's kind of like a
strong will person and nothing i can
handle so she's kind of struggled but
she's really emotional itself that's for
sure that's who i know she is yeah yeah
well your moment with emily's dad the
day of the wedding
one of the best moments all season if
not between honestly you you had some
pretty special moments meeting coven for
the first time stand out moment and then
the moment with emily's dad how would
you describe your relationship with
emily's father well
i would say me and david it's not just
like father-in-law and son-in-law thing
you know me is like a friend like a
mentor you know somebody i really look
up to because he's played a role that
you know father could play to a son a
friend could play to a friend you know a
mentor could play to a student and stuff
like that so
i mean i'm really looking up to him and
we have a really strong connection you
know yeah what did he put in your hands
well you remember the first uh letter
you sent me with yeah
asking permission yeah by that person
yeah and you remember my response i
remember i remember everything until
sometimes i go through it i'm gonna give
you this oh
thanks
no that is personal i'm sorry i can't
really say that yeah that's fine the
tears were enough for me
yeah and i feel like the moment was
really so emotional like you know you
see somebody
like giving you part of his family that
is your responsibility now you should
help me and take care of this i mean
that's a lot
yeah that's a lot this is really sweet
yeah
beautiful beautiful okay well i have
another fan question this goes back to
you hiding your pregnancy
ex polaris wants to know why wouldn't
you just tell your family when you found
out y'all were pregnant in hindsight do
you regret keeping it a secret and i
literally put them on a reality tv show
so i'm like i really want you to enjoy
our wedding and like i don't want you to
like be stressed about you know i don't
know i just didn't want to put that on
them before we got married with
everything else going on
um and i don't regret it because even
afterwards and they ended up not showing
it but
um they didn't say like
it's fine you told us after the wedding
because like they wouldn't have enjoyed
the wedding as much you know so um no i
don't i don't regret it and then i had
like alcohol you know like at the
wedding and at the rehearsal yeah there
were people who felt as if you were
drinking for real
i know
yeah
what was funny is like the day
was it the day before the rehearsal
i was thinking oh my gosh because i got
non-alcoholic beer like a heineken or
something and it's the same
bottle as the original one but it has a
different label it has like zero zero on
it so i told my mom that we had to get
koozies so because we couldn't show like
the labels you know on tv so i was like
we have to get koozies made for the
rehearsal dinner so you know blah blah
blah and she was like oh my gosh so then
we went and we got it made but really so
no one knew i was drinking non-alcoholic
beer like my family so i would like take
the cap off because that was a different
color really quick and like stick it in
my koozie and yeah and then i had like
fake wine and sparkling champagne at the
wedding so
a lot of people thought i was like
i can tell she she was a little tipsy
yeah no i faked it the whole time i'm a
very good banker
yeah oh emily
i am
well kobe you're working now
congratulations what food are you in
like what are you doing
um i work as a qc with an asphalt
company
yeah yeah road pavement are you enjoying
it
oh it doesn't matter right now
that's right i hear that that is right i
have this other fan question from kpas
kaye wants to know why did you think it
was more important to spend money on a
ring and a wedding ceremony instead of
saving so you and kobe can get your own
place as a family
well i do have enough savings to get our
own place as a family so i wanted a
wedding um and i wanted a ring
you know
we're gonna leave it at that
i'm like you know i've worked
very hard since i was 14 and people love
to think i have no money and i'm like i
live with my parents all i do is save
money you know what i mean so
um i did
i
i really i love my ring i just got it
cleaned actually it looks great i saw it
earlier i'm gonna make a real about it
everyone stay tuned
um but no i i do i love my ring in the
wedding honestly i at first wanted to
get married in our home and just have
like 10 people like i wanted to keep it
fairly small
um everybody else wanted a big wedding
uh and it wasn't even that big we had
like 30 35 people
but i'm happy we did that because it was
a lot of fun i mean i had family that
came out like
from california and you know colorado
and texas and his friends came from ohio
so i'm happy we did it and we got to
enjoy um
and celebrate with everybody yeah so you
know some people are gonna say well if
you had enough money to move out why
didn't you all move out
yeah well i'm gonna circle back to what
i said earlier because he wasn't working
and i didn't want to blow all of
our money on a home i felt like that was
irresponsible to buy a house knowing
that we had not a lot of income coming
in
so we really want to wait till he got
his work permit and
you know green card um
and of course now we have all that and
we can't find a house okay next fan
question this is a sensitive one but i
want to hear your thing so april
is curious she wants to know if you ever
think about your kids growing up around
people who don't look like them in
salina kansas
yeah so we don't
plan on stopping atlanta
well i mean do we i mean because we plan
we plan on moving over to canada city
which is bigger there i feel like over
there
you know and you have friends and i have
people over there as well you know it's
still close um i don't know it's like
ever since i had er like we had our kids
um i say i because when i had cobin um i
was like i don't want to move to like
colorado like i want my parents to be
able to come to like their soccer games
and like go to their you know preschool
concerts like it's it really gets
different after you have kids because
you want family close to do that okay
last question do you see yourself doing
another season of 90 days in the future
i do i mean we already signed up for so
we're right this is our lives now yeah
so
yeah um yeah i mean i do i you know we
are very like appreciative that we got
this opportunity and you know luckily my
friend's the one who applied us so
without her i'll remember that
yeah we wouldn't have been on the show
so um i think a lot of
really good opportunities will come from
it um i think that out or you know the
good will out do the bad so um
yeah you know i we've had a lot of dms
asking like are you going to do a
youtube channel are you going to do
you know like are you going to start
any lines so we can like support you
guys
um
i don't know it's just eye opening
because i'm like i did it i thought we
were just on like a season and that's
what it is but i'm like oh wow there are
so many opportunities from this and like
people do are interested in our you know
love story and our family
and i you know he's working now i go to
the gym now at five o'clock in the
morning while he's done with the kids
yes she's living her best life right
yeah it's great i love it
i'm about to get mom car
great yeah yeah i'm excited for you too
is there anything else you want to say
or clear up before we go
i think i don't know you know i feel you
know i i think my dad kind of got a
little bit of a bad rap at the beginning
um
just from the comments like people oh
just calling my dad a racist and um just
want to clarify that my dad and kobe are
best friends and
um
yeah he would do anything for coping
vice i mean they hang out
all the time constantly you know and i'm
like they are good friends my dad is a
saint my mom's a saint um they've gotten
some pretty mean messages about how
they've raised me
and
i was just and i felt so bad about that
like you know imagine you seeing
horrible messages about your daughter
how would you feel yeah you know this is
not who your daughter is so i feel bad
about that and he's also so emotional so
that really weighed down on him and you
know what's so funny when we saw
the
uh what what is that
like the preview for this season like
our season
like we were hardly on it and we saw
everybody else's like you know little
snip of drama and we were like oh my
gosh we have no drama like we were like
we have nothing i kept saying i was like
i'm gonna start a fight at the table
like i'm gonna do something crazy and
then it came out and i was like oh
i am the villain so um you know the
finland and the fan favorite and you
know opposites of track so yeah
we're made for each other